The tumor on my right breast stopped leading with the castor oil on the bandage, and that's
good news and that helps answer the question that actually weeks ago somebody had about
using castor oil on their breast tumor.
It then pulled out a fungus from the tumor.
You suggested sprayed hydrogen peroxide on the tumor under the castor oil.
Yep, so that'd be different than taking cast hydro peroxide orally.
You're using it as a topical and accepted.
So that's where it's beneficial.
So hydro peroxide is H2O2 readily gives off an extra oxygen to kill a bacteria or a virus
or a pathogen, uh, typically, and that's where hydro peroxide orally can be beneficial if
you have like, uh, Hp lower in the stomach or a bacterial infection in the stomach or in
the waddenum, um, but beyond that, it could have other negative issues.
Um, it could actually be a, um, an oxidant that can damage cells and could be a cause of
cancer.
So, um, but using it topically, hydro peroxide is just how you use things, um, this helped
with the fungus, but then the bleeding started to get them trying to stabilize the bleeding
so I can heal the inside out any suggestions.
The other thing you can use is a topical antiseptic is, um, colloidal silver.
So that's another thing that you could use as a topical antiseptic.
You could also make your own with, um, with maybe an oil, uh, mixed with, um, with an essential
oil because you do, you do what you use like something like a regular oil straight.
I mean, that would be burning horribly, but you could maybe mix it with an oil so you could
use that.